[Música]
a
el gobierno de marruecos prepara un
proyecto de ley para la despenalización
del uso terapéutico del cannabis este
país es el mayor productor de cannabis
del mundo y el debate sobre la
despenalización tiene una larga
trayectoria esta planta se cultiva desde
hace siglos de forma ilegal en las
montañas del rif una de las regiones más
empobrecidas del país allí habría más de
50 mil áreas de cultivo y más de 100.000
personas que dependerían exclusivamente
de las plantaciones y según el estudio
del proyecto leyes en legalizar la
industria cannábica podría repercutir
muy positivamente la economía del país
por lo que la mayoría de formaciones
políticas se muestran a favor a
excepción eso sí del partido de la
justicia y el desarrollo único partido
islamista legal en marruecos y que
ostenta ahora mismo la presidencia del
gobierno no obstante estos islamistas no
tienen mayoría parlamentaria ni en los
ministerios más relevantes como es el
caso del interior artífice de este
proyecto ley de llegar al parlamento por
tanto podría ser aprobado con facilidad
y por otra parte en la legalización del
uso terapéutico del cannabis tiene buena
aceptación social pero los agricultores
del reef lamentan que no se haya contado
con ellos para elaborar el proyecto ley
[Música]
desde noviembre pasado el senado
mexicano aprobó las leyes para regular
el uso adulto de la cannabis y las turnó
a la cámara de diputados para su
ratificación luego de más de tres meses
de desacuerdos los diputados apenas se
alistan para discutir las modificaciones
que harán a estas normas que entre otras
cosas permiten la posición de hasta 28
gramos de marihuana para consumo
personal la siembra de cultivos de hasta
6 plantas por casa habitación y crean el
instituto mexicano de cannabis el
organismo que se encargará de otorgar
las licencias para todo el proceso desde
la siembra y cultivo hasta la producción
distribución comercialización y consumo
de cannabis mientras tanto afuera del
senado continúa el plantón de colectivos
cannábicos que exigen ya la aprobación
de esta legislación y piden cambiar el
enfoque comercial por uno más dirigido a
los derechos humanos la prórroga que
concedió la suprema corte de justicia
para que quede lista esta legislación
vence el próximo 30 de abril
[Música]
con la reciente legalización de la
marihuana en el estado de virginia ahora
son 16 estados en la unión americana que
permiten el uso recreacional de la
marihuana para adultos
la medida en virginia sin embargo solo
entrará en vigor a partir del 2024 los
otros estados que recientemente
legalizaron su uso recreacional y
medicinal son nueva jersey dakota del
sur y arizona es de resaltar que en 36
estados ya es permitido el uso medicinal
de la marihuana lo que las pasadas
elecciones de noviembre revelaron es que
este tema de la legalización es de
interés bipartidista en eeuu y de hecho
ya comer líder de los demócratas en el
senado ha dicho que la legalización de
la marihuana a nivel federal es una
prioridad en la agenda del partido hoy
los arrestos por uso comercialización y
posesión de la marihuana son la mitad de
los arrestos por crímenes relacionados
con drogas
[Música]